- Thank you very much.
It's a pleasure being here.
I was told by one of
the fellow fellows
yesterday, or two days
ago, that I don't even
understand your title.
So have no fear.
It was a bit of a
challenge as a chemist
because I'm so used to
talking with structures.
Structures, and the
beauty of structures,
is really a part of what gets
us excited about chemistry.
But I've cut out a
lot of structures
in the hopes of giving
you a sense for what
are some of the key
problems that chemists
are trying to solve.
How does my group
go about trying
to solve a specific
aspect in this larger
picture of chemistry?
And then, I also want to give
you a little bit of a sense
for how does an organic
chemist think about problems?
How do we approach the world?
And so first, I
really, really want
to thank the Daniels family.
So when Judy called
me up last year
and told me this news
of my fellowship,
I had the challenge of
explaining this to my parents.
So my dad worked
in textile plants.
My mom in home
construction sites.
And so the fact
that their daughter
was going to get paid just
to think for nine months
was a little bit mind blowing.
Sort of magical
like a fairy tale.
So I really want to thank
the Daniels family here
for endowing this fellowship
to enable this fairytale.
And hope their generosity
and vision really
inspires a lot of
people beyond me too.
So with that, I'd like
to start, and give you
a sense of first
of all, how is it
that we've gotten therapeutics?
Things to treat disease?
Historically, humans have gotten
this from plants and things
in their environment.
So we'll for example, chew
on birch bark or willow bark
to extract an aspirin-like
component from that.
As you can imagine,
getting something
from a natural
source, it's always
dicey as to how much of
that compound is actually
in the source.
And so, in the late
1800s, chemists
started figuring out
ways of generating
these compounds in pure
form, and to make something
like aspirin.
And many of the
therapeutics that you
might be familiar
with beyond aspirin
that you might
buy at a pharmacy,
are what we call small
molecule therapeutics.
These are relatively
small compounds.
Many of them were inspired
by natural products
from various sources.
And they've been
really changing the way
that we can treat disease.
So in the course
of these studies,
and really going back
to the early 1900s,
with the isolation of insulin--
that protein-- the small 51
amino acid peptide or protein
from the pancreas, we realized
that there was actually
some larger molecules that
could also be therapeutically
interesting and vital.
So many of the
newer therapeutics,
including vaccines as well as
all these monoclonal antibody
therapies you may hear
about in the news now,
are based on what's called
recombinant DNA technology.
And I'll describe that
in a little bit of detail
in the next two slides.
And these are known
as biotherapeutics.
These are quite a bit larger
than the small molecule
therapies that chemists have
been synthesizing or extracting
from natural sources.
And these are known
as biotherapeutics
even when they are chemically
modified in some way.
And this is actually the
fastest growing sector
of the pharmaceutical industry
now is biotherapeutics
for various reasons.
And interestingly, in 2014,
the World Health Organization
identified increased access
to the biotherapeutic products
as a global health priority.
So not just small molecule
therapies, but also
these much larger molecules.
Now, this is a challenge
from a chemistry standpoint.
So we started out by
just isolating insulin
from cow pancreases
and dog pancreases.
And then, as you can imagine,
this is quite tedious.
Some people would have an
immune response against a cow
form of insulin versus human.
And so the first
version of insulin
was synthesized in the 1960s.
Then with the advent of
recombinant DNA technology,
this ability for not
just your own selves
to take genetic information
and make a protein out of it,
but also harness other cells--
whether they're human
or bacterial cells.
We can take those
genes, and then
have that new cell make
a protein of interest.
And now, there's not nearly
as much of a background.
Purification is
still a challenge.
But basing recombinant DNA
technology starting in the 70s
really transformed our ability
to get to biotherapeutics--
these larger biomolecules.
And this was really
a result of lots,
of lots of interesting
chemistry that was developed.
So why is it that it is so
easy to sequence a gene now?
There are a lot of chemists who
worked on ways of enzymatically
synthesizing genes, being
able to find ways to analyze
those genes, as well as
being able to synthesize
the little fragments
that are used in what's
called a polymerase
chain reaction to make
many copies of a gene.
So these are all
different chemical
and biochemical
techniques that had
to be developed in order
for structure function
relationships to be easy to do
with genes, genetic material,
nucleic acids.
While I was a post doc at
Stanford in the late 1990s,
there's a lot of
technology that was
starting to be developed
on this end too.
So Bruce Merrifield
won the Nobel Prize
in chemistry in the
1980s for coming up
with an automated way
of stringing together
amino acids to make peptides.
So that now, if you're
interested in a specific gene
or peptide, you don't
have to contact a chemist.
You can just go online,
put in the sequence,
and order your favorite
gene or protein.
There's a lot of different
methods for analysis
of proteins,
purification of proteins,
as well as enzymatic
methods that
now make it relatively
straightforward although still
challenging depending
on the sequence,
to access genetic material
and to access proteins
from synthetic methods so
that you can get very well
defined compounds.
So it's one compound.
Not a mixture the way you might
get from a natural source.
Now, we discovered after
insulin it doesn't end there.
What is genetically encoded,
you make the protein.
But after that,
there's all sorts
of modifications that can
happen to that protein that
affect its ability
to for example,
transfer across membranes.
How long it will
circulate in your blood
will depend on these
other modifications.
And one of those very
important modifications
that happens to proteins is
the addition of lots of sugars.
Here's just a schematic
of a large sugar.
These sugars can be
large enough that they're
as large as the protein itself.
And historically,
biochemists would just
cleave the sugars off and study
the protein calling it good.
Because oftentimes,
the same protein
could have a slightly different
bunch of sugars on it.
So it made the problem
a lot more complicated.
Now, especially with all the
monoclonal antibody therapies,
we're discovering the
sugars actually matter.
They matter not just in the
pharmacokinetic properties.
In other words, how well
does this biotherapeutic
circulate in your
bloodstream for example?
How quickly does it get cleared?
But it can also
make a difference
on the actual biology of
how that monoclonal antibody
interacts.
And so this has really led
to an increased understanding
that we need to figure out
how to study sugars too.
Not just ignore them.
And so now, you look
at this scheme here.
Why is it that the sugars
are so difficult to study?
And I'll give you a
few slides specifically
as to why these
are so challenging.
But basically, when I set up
my independent research career
in 2000, I thought
well, it would
be nice to be able to get
these sorts of tools--
to be able to have
commercial chemical
synthesis of a carbohydrate
that doesn't take years
and costs tens of
thousands of dollars
for a simple
trisaccharide stringing
three sugars together.
We need better
analytical methods.
We also ideally, could perhaps
harness biology to help us make
some of these compounds.
And fortunately, for the field
the United States National
Academy of Sciences put
out a report in 2012
that identified
these exact areas
as increasingly important
areas that we need
to really fund and develop.
The inherent chemistry.
Essentially, it said,
chemists we need you.
We need to figure out
the tools and techniques
to study this class
of biomolecules
that mimics the way
we've studied peptides
and nucleic acids.
So why is it that the
study of carbohydrates
has lagged so far behind
the study of peptides
and nucleic acids?
Well, here is your first
chemical structure.
So here is a very, very
basic carbohydrate.
So it's basically a backbone
of carbon with water on it.
That is carbohydrate.
Now, if I just draw
it this way, glucose
is the most common carbohydrate.
And that is what's powering
your brain right now so you
can pay attention.
But I can't tell what
this actually is just
from looking at its structure.
Because it turns out, in
three dimensional space,
there's many possibilities.
And in fact, this is
the many possibilities
that a structure drawn flat
like this actually could be.
Now, not only for many of
you, but for many chemists,
they run screaming
when they see this
because it's just confusing.
This is like looking out at
the Harvard Marching Band,
and seeing a whole bunch of
crimson blazers and black pants
and going, where is my friend?
So I have color coded some
of these sugars for you.
So basically, the difference
between each of these sugars
is just how this hydroxyl group
as it's called, this alcohol,
is oriented in space around this
three dimensional structure.
And so to me, this
is fascinating
because you really need to
have an understanding of how
this looks in three
dimensions, not just two.
But it makes it a killer problem
from an analytical standpoint
and a synthetic
standpoint if you
look at all these
different possibilities.
And so if you look
at the possibilities
for making different
kinds of sugar chains,
even something very simple
like just hooking two things
together, there are four
different nucleotides
for deoxynucleic acid.
You get four different
possibilities.
You can get 16 possibilities
when you make a dimer.
There are about 20 amino
acids for proteins.
That leaves you with 400 diners.
If you only take
these 16 sugars,
you can find 2,560
different possibilities
of connecting those two sugars.
And believe me, there's
many, many other
naturally occurring sugars.
There's literally hundreds.
So you can start seeing this
becomes an incredible problem
in terms of if somebody hands
me a sample from a bacteria
that I've never seen,
what is the sugar?
It is extremely challenging to
tell you what that sugar is.
And so then, of course, it
makes it very challenging
to develop a vaccine
based on that sugar
if you can't even
tell what it is.
And so this is part of the
fun part of this project.
But it's also part of
the frustrating part
of looking at sugars.
So this is part
of a basic problem
that chemists are
facing right now.
If you look back to the 1800s,
chemists were empirically
looking at a lot of
different reactions,
and trying to
figure out what are
all these different elements.
And this is my redrawing of
Mendeleev's Periodic Table.
This is how he drew it.
But I basically just
turned it on its side.
So it looks a little bit more
like the modern periodic table.
But he basically took
empirical information
from different reactions
with different elements,
and then started
seeing patterns.
And the beauty of
this periodic table
is the fact that it gives
you predictive power.
So these question
marks were elements
that he predicted
or later discovered.
And I can look at this
and say, ah, sulfur,
which is one way that you can
link a sugar to a protein,
should have similar
but slightly different
properties than the
oxygen linkages that link
some other sugars to proteins.
So if you're looking at
two different elements,
the periodic table
is a fantastic way
of generating hypotheses.
Now, one thing I should
make you aware of
is the fact that the vast
majority of these elements
we really don't know
that much about yet.
And the reactivity and how they
can react with other compounds
is largely still
unknown surprisingly,
even though we've had this basic
heuristic for studying these.
Now, my focus has been primarily
on the carbon and the oxygen
up here.
And this is in the study
of organic chemistry.
It's all the different
cool structures
that carbon can make
especially in natural settings
like in human biology.
And so the next sort of leap
was this idea of how does
a group of these atoms react?
And so many of you are familiar
with these two compounds
in their aqueous dilute form--
ethanol, or vodka
in it's aqueous
dilute form, or acetic
acid, or vinegar.
And ask anyone who's tried
vinegar versus vodka,
they're quite different.
And you see it from a
chemical standpoint here,
this is an alcohol.
And this is an acid.
These are what we call two
different functional groups.
And interestingly, the entire
undergrad organic chemistry
classes that I and many
people have taught,
are based on this idea
of functional groups.
It allows me to compare and have
some predictive power about how
an alcohol might react and
interact with other compounds
versus how an acid might react.
What I found amusing was
this quote from Saul Patai
and this whole first
volume in the series
on functional groups in 1964.
It made me argue
that the treatment
of a single functional group is
not in accordance with the most
modern principles.
Still, organic
chemistry and in most
places taught according
to functional groups.
And the mnemotechnic
advantages of this division
are so great that
it will probably not
be displaced for
many decades to come.
And in fact, it still
hasn't been displaced.
It's exactly how I
still teach this.
Now, you may recall from
my structures of sugars,
that it's all alcohols.
Now, what do I do?
So here, I have
those same 16 sugars.
And now, all I've done is
remove one of these hydroxyls
to give you the entire
16 deoxy series.
I could add acids.
I can make literally
dozens and dozens
of different carbohydrates.
So the problem now is there
is no heuristic model.
And now, that all of
these functional groups
are identical, they're just
altering their placement
in space.
We don't have great
ways of predicting
how one compound will react
versus another compound
will react.
And this is one of the
frontiers in chemistry
now is, how do you deal
with a molecule that
has all these identical
functional groups
in the same molecule?
How do I predict how
this molecule will react?
And where for example?
Now, when I look at
something like this, and go,
OK, the differences
are not going
to be nearly as great as the
difference between ethanol
and vinegar for example.
How am I going to deal with
these more subtle differences?
And so one thing that
my group has approached
taking this problem is looking
at this entire set as opposed
to just focusing on
something like just glucose
or just galactose, which
are found in humans.
So three of these sugars
have been studied a lot.
The rest have not.
In part, because they're
difficult to access.
So we're looking at
the entire isomer set.
And we also realize
that we're going
to have to do some
very carefully
controlled experiments
to be able to tease out
subtle differences.
Now, one of the other fun things
about being an organic chemist
is actually doing chemistry.
It's really pretty much the
whole mind body experience.
I get to use my senses of sense.
A lot of chemists
used to taste, but we
tend not to do that anymore.
Sights.
Sounds.
When you're running
an experiment,
you're fully all in using your
brain as well as your body.
The problem then is there can
be a large lead time in learning
the techniques of chemistry.
And so, it's also
I realize we're
going to have to start
thinking about how to take some
of the human factor out of this
in order to run experiments
reproducibly to be
able to get access
to some of the underlying
phenomena of nature
of comparing these compounds.
So today, I'm going
to tell you primarily
about our chemical synthesis.
But my group really approaches
these problems as interrelated.
And that also distinguishes
my group from many others.
I realized on the
analytical end for example,
we don't have authentic
standards of compounds
to develop analytical
methods because they're
so difficult to make.
The scale at which I
need to make compounds
is in large part dictated
by the analytical methods
because they require a fair
amount of the compound.
And so I realized these were
all interrelated problems.
And so my group is trying
to study these basically
as a whole system.
And trying to not just
optimize one reaction.
But it pushed the
entire system forward.
And I'd be happy in question
and answer or later to talk more
about this work.
But today, I'm to
tell you a little bit
about how we're approaching
the chemical synthesis problem.
How do we start
looking at something
that's so complicated?
So I mentioned the
fact that we really
wanted to be able to take a
little bit of the human factor
out of making these molecules,
and why is it so difficult?
You saw the basic structure.
Stringing these things together
can be quite lengthy syntheses.
And the reproducibility is
not because we're somehow
uniquely unable to reproduce so
much as if you have a 20 step
process or a 40 step
process, it's unlikely
that many people are
going to be motivated
and rich enough to
reproduce the process.
And so that's a big problem.
And this is a problem with
nucleic acids and peptides
too until commercial
automated synthesis
platforms became available.
Now, the ways that
these became available
was attaching everything
onto a solid phase.
Literally, you can attach
your first building block
onto a solid phase, grow
your biopolymer chain,
rinse away all your reactions,
reagents that you don't need,
and then you can
grow your chain.
In fact, that's exactly
what we tried initially.
But there are various
problems with that approach
when you look at sugars.
There's still a lot
of difficult linkages
that I won't go into details.
You still need stuff
to put on your machine.
The actual building blocks
that you put on the machine.
Analyzing the products
can be challenging.
Purifying the products
And still is for peptides from
automated peptide synthesis.
And then ideally, we'd also
be able to interface anything
that we use to be able to
make carbohydrates reliably.
We should be able
to also interface
that with the already
available methods
to make peptides
in order to look
at that bio therapeutic space
in a very systematic way
to do systematic structure
functional relationships
as we're calling it.
So I had the opportunity 3 1/2
weeks ago to go to the German
apothecary museum in Heidelberg.
And frankly, I
felt right at home.
In fact, going to the museum
I passed by Bunsen's house.
And many of you might be
familiar with the Bunsen
burner.
And I was so excited.
I told my husband you've
got to get a picture of me.
And the people walking by
probably thought I was crazy.
But I didn't care.
Look, how many times have
I used the Bunsen burner?
It's great because now I
don't have to use bellows.
That was the only
thing in that museum
that I realized electricity
was a great thing
to be able to control heat.
But otherwise, we still
have mortar and pestles,
we still have sand baths,
we've got all sorts
of really cool glassware.
The only problem
with this approach
is that many times frankly,
in my graduate career,
I would reproduce the
prep from the 1800s.
And it worked beautifully.
Crystals would crash out.
You're like, you felt
this visceral connection
to this chemist
who's been long dead.
The problem is there
was a long lag time
in learning all the techniques.
When you read a
procedure, they just
assume that you know how to
put the glassware together,
and how you might
heat or do anything.
And so there's quite a
bit of training period
in learning how to do this.
So I realized that
we're going to have
to start-- if we're looking at
these very subtle differences
in reactivity that we're
looking at with carbohydrates,
this sort of manual approach
is introducing enough errors
that they might
obscure or obliterate
the subtle differences
that we're looking for.
And so, basically, that was
one of the major driving
motivations in
automating senses.
Of course, it can be
important in terms
of trying to develop
the biotherapeutics,
but I also see it
as central to being
able to understand the
underlying fundamental
chemistry and how
these molecules react.
So why do we want
to automate this?
Some of you may recognize
these sugar building blocks.
We have individual
building blocks
that we'd like to
put into a machine,
and then just string
them together.
Three to nine of
these sugars would
be enough to be
able to start doing
a lot of fundamental
biology work, as well
as the biotherapeutics
[INAUDIBLE]..
And of course, the reason we
want to automate it in part
is to eliminate a
lot of tedious labor.
There are only a handful
of carbohydrate chemists
on the planet.
Not nearly enough
to feed the need
for being able to make
these kinds of structures.
So ideally, we'd be
able to easily generate
diverse sugars in very
well-controlled sequences
so that we can look at the
function based on the sequence.
And the thing that
I didn't fully
appreciate until we
started doing automation
15 years ago in my
lab is that it also
forces you to develop readily
reproducible chemistry.
So where a needle
goes into a solution
can make a difference
in the reactivity,
and the outcome of the reaction.
And so all of these
things turn out
to matter when it comes to
actually running your reaction.
And that's what we need
to discern the underlying
logic of these relatively subtle
differences between compounds.
So how do we go
about doing that?
So here's Kevon, who
is a senior graduate
student in the lab with one
of our three synthesizers.
Our goal, like I said. is
just to string three to nine
of these sugars
together reliably.
And this, I have to say just
the actual robotics of this
is quite a bit more complicated
than a solid phase peptide
synthesizer because now,
I'm not just rinsing resins.
But I'm asking everything
to be done in solution.
Not enough solid
phase where you need
lots of excess reagents
and building blocks
but in solution.
And that's really what's
unique about our platform.
And ideally, the reactions must
be amenable to liquid handling
because this entire thing
we have to make a solution,
have a robot deliver
that to the glass flask,
and I'll show you here.
Basically, we have our component
with a little basically tag.
It's like a little
affinity tag that we
attach under our sugar--
maintains a solution.
And then, we can couple
each of our building blocks
and grow the chain like that.
So basically, to
get this to work,
we need to develop a
purification system
to be able to get this
fish out from the mess
of other compounds
that are in there.
We need sufficient
amounts of these building
blocks, which is something we're
still very actively working on.
And then, we of course need
methods to put the building
blocks together in a way that
a stupid machine or a robot
can deliver them.
And so I don't expect
you to look at all--
here are some of the details
if you're interested.
But basically, this
machine has a whole bunch
of glass reactor blocks.
A little bit step up from
the old apothecary lab.
Certainly costs more.
And then we have a robotic
arm that delivers the reagents
as we need them.
And it's all
basically controlled
from the central computer.
And then it does all
the purification steps
to be able to do this
sort of iterative process,
and string together
sugars one by one.
Now, the development
of the process
has allowed us to make
oligosaccharide synthesis
a much more reproducible
process than it
was before when we had to
rely on each individual person
doing these things.
We use the computer to
tell the various machine
parts what to do.
And all the variables, including
the timing, are specified.
So how long does
it take from where
one reagent goes into that
flask versus another one?
That is programmed now as
opposed to a person going
in there and manually adding
and not necessarily writing
down how long it took.
And you see a huge difference
between a first year graduate
student and a fifth
year graduate student--
how long it takes to get the
second reagent in the flask.
And the other great
thing is these programs
can be easily shared
between researchers
in a much more exact way than
a written protocol can be.
Though the other thing that's
nice about the automation
platform, and I won't
go into details,
it's forced us to
develop new chemistry.
And that's always exciting from
a development point of view--
is that OK, what is now that
we have this process what are
the next set of limitations?
And that's led us
into developing
some chemistry of something
an element that Mendeleev
didn't get the molecular weight
correct but did do existed.
Bismuth, which is once
again, on of those elements
that there's
surprisingly little known
about in terms of its
reactivity and chemistry.
It's also allowed us to adapt.
Look at how do you adapt a
manual process into something
that you can do on a machine.
And sometimes the
chemistry doesn't just
translate automatically.
You have to develop new
kinds of chemistries.
And so that's also been
a large part of my lab
is thinking about how do
we go about developing
new chemistries, and what
kind of new chemistries
can we discover now that
we have this essentially
creative limitation in having
to use an automation platform.
Now, so far, very few
reactions have been shown
to work on automated chemistry.
So the vast majority of
different kinds of chemistry
that are run in the world are
still done the old fashioned
way-- manually.
In this particular case,
we use a computer program
to tell the various
machine parts what to do,
which is not a very common
skill among chemists.
Very few chemists have
computer programming skills
or background.
The interesting thing though
is if you took that code
off this computer,
you'd have no idea
what it was actually running.
Nowhere in the code
does it tell you
what this entire
complex actually is.
And the other criticism
is this machine
is only accessible to
those of us who have
extremely well-funded labs.
And so then, how do you also
make this more accessible?
If you want to take all
the manual processes,
the hundreds of
different chemistry
processes that are being
run around the world,
and make them into
something that
could be machine readable
so we can ultimately
mine that data to look for
these more subtle effects that
are not as obvious as a
difference between one
functional group or another
or one element or another.
But more subtle differences
like, why is this hydrogen
different than that one?
Or why is this hydroxyl
different than the other?
Ideally, we'd have a method that
all reactions will be produced
in a way that's
reproducible, and produces
data that's machine readable
that we can ultimately
mine that data.
So that's the bigger
picture long term goal
in the idea of automating.
So part of what I also
did in coming to Radcliffe
is thinking about OK, we
have this fancy machine.
It's interesting
training students
to use the machine
because I mean
I was trained as a
traditional chemist
too in that you
have to give up some
of that visceral fun of
running your reactions
when you have the machine do it.
And as soon you make a
mistake in programming it,
and the needle doesn't
go where you say it does,
I just want to go
back to the bench
and run it the
old fashioned way.
So there's definitely
issues of just adapting
to having a machine run
your reactions for you.
And so in thinking
about this, part of it
is this is a huge
leap from those glass
retorts in the Heidelberg
Apothecary Museum.
It's very, very different.
And so when I think about how
most chemists set up reactions,
we have a round
bottom glass flask,
we have some way to heat
our reaction for example,
and some way to
add our reagents.
There are all different parts.
And we put this together.
And I remember being
trained as a first year
by a senior graduate
student in another group,
you look in there and this
set up was a beauty to behold.
It was an aesthetically
pleasing experience just
to look at this reaction set up.
And learning how to do
that, and do it reproducibly
takes a little bit of time.
So one of the things I'm doing
with Benjamin Lee, who's here
with one of my Radcliffe's
research partners,
and Alex [? Majelous ?]
who's a senior graduate
student in the Pentelute Lab
at MIT where I'm also working,
is think about how
do we make setting up
an automated chemical process
as easy as setting up LEGOs.
I played with a lot of LEGOs
and building blocks as a kid.
And the beauty is you have a
limited set of building blocks,
and you can build
just about anything.
And we'd like to be
able to do that too.
But in a way that you can
reproduce it by making it
machine readable and codeable.
So how do we make setting up
reactions using automation
as easy as building the
usual glassware setups?
How do we code the setup itself?
Not just the program that
tells the setup what to do.
But you should be able
to look at the program
and say, ah, this is
what I need to go set up
this particular setup.
And then, we also have to think
about what should the output
files be in order to actually
make the whole process machine
readable so that
all the data ideally
from every lab across the planet
can be produced in such a way
that you can start looking
at this data using machine
algorithms.
And so this is something
that Benjamin, and Alex,
and I have been working
on in the last semester.
And it's been a lot of fun.
So basically, we have
components in the lab
like this valve that can switch
from one thing to another.
And you look at the back of it
it's got a little serial port.
And basically, now,
the little components--
you'll see you'll notice
a difference here--
is basically another computer
chip that has a Wi-Fi signal.
So this is basically a
relatively straightforward
simple method where we can
take some of the components
that we have in
the lab and Wi-Fi
enable them to
put them onto what
we call the internet of things.
How many of you have heard
of the internet of things?
OK.
So yeah.
So we don't have a lot of
internet of things things
yet in the chemistry labs.
And so how do we go
about doing that?
So the nice thing about having
this as opposed to cabling
is now, you can
literally mix and match
all these pieces in your
fume hood or on your bench.
And then, have them
all talk to one other
with a computer program.
And so what Benjamin, Alex,
and I've been working on,
is actually the program.
How do we think about this
in a very modular approach
so that the program spits
out what were the parts?
What did we actually
put together?
Because we're going
to have to connect
all these different parts
usually with tubing.
And then, how do we
get also a program
that actually runs the process?
So the idea is at the
end of this project,
hopefully by May
or earlier, we'll
have computer program code
that if we gave you the code,
you could not only have a list
of all the components you would
need that you could then
physically assemble and put
together--
I promise not to do
it in Byerly Hall--
in your fume hood,
and then basically
also have the program to run
those components so that you
could run the reaction
in Bangladesh, and Ghana,
in China, and India,
in Canada, anywhere
around the world
exactly the same way
that we ran it here in
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
And so to that end
basically, we have
the components, the
program that codes
not just the protocol which
has been done with automation,
but also the modules set up.
So Benjamin programmed this so
that he hears the components
that we need for this
particular reaction
in a continuous process.
Here's the manifold, the pumps,
prints out the components.
Tells you exactly the
type of tubing to hook up
all these different components.
And it also spits out
a nice little diagram
so you get a sense of OK, if my
set up doesn't look like this,
I've done something wrong.
I'm missing a component
here somewhere or the other.
And so now, we're going about
also developing ultimately will
be a graphical user interface.
But we notice graphical user
interfaces date themselves
quite quickly compared to
the underlying programming.
So that's why we're
waiting for that
to be last so that it can
also be easily updated.
And so now, we have the
first sort of modular way
to be able to put
components together.
And we're also hoping that all
this data will be in a machine
readable format so
that we can deposit it,
and anyone across the
planet could actually
start mining that
data from the outputs.
So part of what we've been
using this setup for initially,
is to be able to link a
sugar to an amino acid.
The very basic
component of a peptide.
So this goes back to
the title of the talk,
how do I marry the automated
oligosaccharides synthesis
to the automated
peptide synthesis?
Well, the peptide
synthesizers use amino acids
in a protected form.
So the reactive group is
blocked with something
to make it less reactive.
And ideally, we'd like to be
able to put a sugar on there.
Right now, you can
certainly do that.
And they're extremely costly.
In the case of this, an
amino acid with an oxygen
linked here you
can buy that sugar,
but it's about $10,000 a gram.
And you start thinking, ah,
no wonder lots of people
aren't working on this compound.
Labs aren't that well-funded.
And the starting with a process
my post-doc at IU developed,
we have now, developed this
into a more automated process
whereby we can flow in, make
a solution of our sugar,
a solution of our
protected amino acid,
and then in one step be able to
link these two things together
so that after
purification, this is
ready to go into a
solid phase peptide
synthesizer in the Pentelute Lab
at MIT in this particular case.
So it's the first
continuous process
to make sure modified amino
acids is ready for solid phase
peptide synthesis.
And it's in the process
now of being automated.
And it requires only
one step from these two
commercial starting
materials, which
also makes it more feasible.
So we basically figured
we brought the price down
for about $10,000 a gram
to about $10 a gram,
so that we can start putting
these pieces together
to be able to start synthesizing
glycosylated or sugar modified
peptides, and looking
at that entire space.
So one of the other
appeals of this fellowship
is that there is a
large glycobiology
center that moved to Harvard
Med School two years ago.
And I'm also working with
Rick Cummings and his lab
there to start looking
at generating antibodies
for example specifically
against sulfur linked
sugars versus the more commonly
oxygen and nitrogen linked
sugars.
Because frankly, we didn't
even know until two years ago
that humans had sulfur linked
sugars naturally occurring
in their proteins.
So we're quite excited
about this possibility that
opens up based on
the synthesis itself
developing the synthesis.
And so, how far along
are we to making
precision biotherapeutics?
Well, I hope to give
you a sense today
that the chemistry
for stringing sugars
together is becoming much more
well-developed than it was even
in the last 10 years.
We do have machines now that
can string together the sugars.
But access to the
sugar building blocks
themselves has turned
into the major hurdle.
And so that's the
other reason why
I'm excited about
lab scale automation
of continuous processes to
be able to bring the steps
to make the sugar
building blocks themselves
into something feasible
so we could easily
get kilos of material
to drive that chemistry.
We have an easy modular
approach process
to automate the
chemical synthesis
that we hope should allow the
much more widespread adoption
of automation to build databases
of reproducible chemical
reaction data.
The goal that
Alex, and Benjamin,
I set, and Miles Ingram, who's
the new Radcliffe research
partner who just started
this week on this project,
is to make this cheap
enough that a primarily
undergraduate institution can
easily adopt these automation
processes and incorporate
them into their labs
in training their students
and in generating data sets.
Integrating automated
sugar and peptide synthesis
is ongoing with now, these
much more affordable building
blocks.
So we're quite excited about
looking at and exploring
this glycopeptide space now.
And then, ultimately
of course, I'd
like to be able to do enough
chemistry to start developing
rules to predict the
reactivities of all
those different sugar
structures I've shown you.
And that's where
I think automation
and artificial intelligence
algorithms are really
going to be needed.
But for that, we need the data.
And so the automation,
we're one step closer
to being able to get that
reproducible data that we
can start to machine read.
And so with that, only
thing left for me to do
is thank the many researchers
that has helped me.
This is my research group back
at Indiana who's helped me.
Here's Miles and Benjamin, who
are Radcliffe research partners
along with Alex in the
Pentelute Lab at MIT.
The various funding sources.
And that basically
is part of the joy
of being a professor is working
with a lot of talented students
from around the world.
So with that, I'd be very
happy to answer questions.
Thank you.